Welcome to AAB Testing Podcast, your modern testing podcast.
Your hosts, Alan and Brent, will be here to guide you through topics on testing, leadership,
agile, and anything else that comes to mind.
Now on with the show.
Welcome to AAB Testing episode 231.
I am back today with a very, very special guest, somebody who honestly isn't qualified
to be a guest on the podcast, but after a lot of begging and a lot of groveling, including
a letter I got that, well, Satya wouldn't sign it, but one of Satya's, a little bit
of Satya's drool was on the letter.
I agreed to have a special guest on.
For everybody in the land of AAB testing, please welcome back Brent Jensen.
Uh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, episode 231.
No, no, this, this is hello everyone.
Sorry for the delay.
Welcome to episode two 20, none of the, none of the other shit counted.
Alan screwed up and started doing the three, four, three series on this channel.
I had good guests and I have, I have more guests lined up that you may or may not
come to.
So you are, until you earn your place back, you are a guest on this podcast.
Sorry.
It's the way it works.
And if all three listeners want to, want to vote in on that, it is democratic.
I get three votes.
They get one each and Brent, you don't get any because you're a guest.
All right.
Okay.
Just like old times, just like old times.
So the problem is with the guests, this is my podcast, I'll talk, but you'll get
your chance.
The problem with guests is I'm nice to them and I miss being mean to someone on
the podcast.
So just, it's good to have you back, Burt, Burt, Bart, Brent.
Yes.
Uh, good to be back.
Uh, I, I'm going to go ahead and, uh, as you would, you will, uh, continue to
ignore, um, Alan's random attempts at, at clearly in incorrect information, uh,
as I was saying earlier, again, everyone welcomed episode two 20 and, uh, we're
just going to go ahead and keep the three, four, three episodes on this
channel because why have to, um, anyway, uh, I'll just, just say, um, there's a
lot of things that I, I, I don't understand like where the hell spy came
from.
Dude, aren't you, don't you listen to the podcast?
I've talked about this.
Uh, I listened to, it's no different, like, do you listen to the
podcast?
Like, it's no different than before.
But don't you want to hear how much better it sounds when you're not on it?
Oh, no, I don't, I don't need to know that.
I, I, I like, I've known that from, from God, April, whatever, April 11.
Okay, so let's, let's take a minute and I'll catch you up on what I've been
up to since our last podcast recording over a year ago.
And then maybe you can tell us what you've been up to and, and maybe
contribute some topics to this podcast.
How does that sound?
Uh, sure.
But there's one very quickly I wanted, I was interested in.
What's the story behind the replay of the hugs?
Oh, because behind the scenes I am working very hard on getting hugs to
come back on to talk about his Vibium project, uh, which is super cool.
Um, it's basically replacing Slending with AI agent, uh, UI software.
So it just, just yet another AI influence tool in testing space.
And hugs is also really cool.
And I want to hear how his croissant cooking is coming along.
So the replay there was I had been working on it.
He said, yeah, he would do it.
And then he's ignored me since then.
So, uh, still working on it.
He's just very busy.
I think, uh, would like to have him back on.
So that was, I had kind of a verbal confirmation from it or
maybe a text confirmation, and then he kind of decided, nah, I'm busy.
So that's, that's the story of the replay there.
And I was going to do more replays.
Also, I didn't have any other guests lined up.
Uh, I have a few more coming up.
I'll invite you if you want to come along.
I can do, I, apparently I know how to do this without you.
That's why this is episode two 31 and not to 20.
Uh, and so that's the story.
I'm sorry about the, um, whatever's in your throat.
I'm sure it's not sanitary.
Uh, so last time you and I spoke on the podcast was in the end of
March last year and I was about to go on this hike and, and Brent can see,
but there's this little map behind me.
And I walked from there all the way up to there.
And I'm pointing from Mexico to Canada.
And, uh, one thing on the PCT is, uh, because there are 14 people named
Ryan and, uh, you don't want to call them all Ryan.
Did you see Ryan?
I don't know which one, uh, over time, people get trail names
and you're kind of known by your trail name.
And like one year and two days ago, uh, this, I was hiking with this
couple from Pennsylvania named a spout and Yeti, and, uh, I was taking
some voice notes into my phone and just kind of do it, doing, doing
the, the Allen observation stuff.
And she runs up to me and says, you act like a spy.
Are you a spy?
And I said, if I was, I couldn't tell you.
She goes, well, that's your trail name and it stuck.
And so for the next forever, people, I'm not, wait, was it an accident
then that spot is also sort of an amalgam of those two people's
trail names, pure accident spout yet.
Oh, it is.
I didn't even think of that before.
Nice pattern matching.
Good job.
No, it was because they thought I was a spy and then, uh, it's stuck
and people were happy to call me that and people still call me that.
And it helps me identify with that world I was in.
So, uh, I am a spy and so, uh, but also I have a government name as well.
Um, they, they, they both work.
And so I did the, I did the walk.
I came back.
I, uh, lots of stuff in between there.
I sat and stared at the wall for actually I sat outside and stared at
the sky for like three months, trying to figure out if I, how I fit into a world
where I had more stuff that would fit in my backpack and then I started applying
for jobs and saw how wildly crazy the job market is and, uh, been
do a little bit of that.
I've been doing a little bit of, um, and pick it up some little bit
of side work here and there.
I've been doing some marketing work for smart bear, uh, have some other
things coming up where I'm helping some companies get started.
Uh, doing a little bit of leadership coaching.
And, uh, as I told, told a friend of mine this morning, you know, this, at
this stage, I am approaching a five figure salary for this year.
So, so because yeah, so that was shocking because as I was, as I was
listening, I was the way, because I know you in the way that came across.
I'm like, Oh, wow.
Congratulations.
Wait, five figures.
I had to do a double take there.
Yeah.
I'm just going to pause a second.
I'm not sure if when you shake your head around, but your microphone drops
out, keep on going with all you're approaching, I could, let me know if
you want me to switch Mike right now.
I'm happy your other one was worse.
I think it's when you shake your head around and talk.
Um, it gets a little weird.
So other because the microphone's in the headphones and, and.
Obviously it has bounce and come back and yeah.
So, yeah, it's cool.
So that's what I've been up to.
Um, I will, I will tell you, I will share something, uh, briefly, um,
that I think will be a great surprise to you, all of our audience.
And that is, um, three weeks ago.
Uh, I, uh, I finally, I was inspired by something I saw on YouTube.
I went in, um, to the appropriate professional and I walked out
officially, officially diagnosed ADA.
Like I know this is just a shock to everyone on the channel.
Right.
Really?
Oh my gosh.
So surprising.
Yeah.
Um, but you know, just to keep the same vibe of the podcast going, uh,
I am not on my medication today.
Um, okay.
Well that that's probably appropriate to make sure we get the
full AB testing experience.
Yes.
Um, the, did I finish?
We were talking about me, but I think I'm done.
I did the hike.
I came back looking for jobs.
Um, I keep on running into old people.
I knew I'm going to, I'm not going to name drop the one from today.
Somebody actually, I was, I saw a job I liked, didn't think I would like
I might even go into it right now.
And I pinged the person cause I knew them at Microsoft.
You know them too.
I'll name them offline and they, and they remember me.
So you did great work and it's the network that really helps.
I am going to drop one name from the past.
Um, there have been a couple of real, like, like honestly, I'm
going to drop one company here, a couple of jobs, uh, that have just
like fit me to a T at GitLab, um, CI company and the hiring
manager, the CTO, do you remember Siva test architect from windows Siva pad?
Um, yes, I do.
So he's the CTO there.
And I did that dude favors back in the day.
I pinged him on LinkedIn.
He said, yeah, just apply whatever.
And then they, and then they, they sent me like, you know, we decided
to move forward with more qualified applicants, so I don't know
what's going on there.
That one's weird.
Sounds like I don't want to work there, but I'm going to, I'm going
to name and shame one there.
And then, um, but the rest of all done pretty well.
Like it's a weird market.
Like I, I, I have every time I've gotten even to a recruiter almost
has been through a contact, someone who's someone who I know from my
network and then, uh, and then weird stuff happens.
I don't know.
I, so, um, anyway, that that's my story.
Go on, go on, tell me about your story.
What are you going to, um, so I still at Microsoft.
Um, and, uh, what kind of software is Microsoft making these days?
Is it software?
Right.
I would say the most of the engineers that I'm aware of right now are, are,
are building markdown files like crazy.
Um, that's the.
Yep.
I know what you're talking about.
Yeah.
Uh, and I think it's in alignment.
I do have a topic suggestion, like in terms of the background, uh, when
I, when I'm ready for that, I'll get to sort of a background there.
Um, I, Alan, um, was aware of this.
I told him a while ago.
Um, the position that I held at Microsoft, um, up until two days ago, I
started in a new role, still at the company, but started in a new role two
days ago, uh, and are you installing cat, cat, cat seven into to Satya's,
uh, Porsche?
No.
Okay.
Just checking.
No, no.
Please continue.
I have no idea where that came from, but that's because you haven't listened
to the podcast for the inside joke.
I do know that, that, that the joke is, is that, is that I'm like ankle
grabbing for Satya or something, but, um, something like that.
Yeah.
You've, you have put GPUs into his greenhouse.
Who knows why?
Um, you've done a lot of stuff for the guy.
Nice work.
So I'll just say, um, the position I held last time was, was, was not
an ideal position for me, um, uh, and in a way that was problematic.
Uh, I'll just put it that way.
Um, and so I, I have spent a good portion of the last, last year in a
high stress situation, trying to get, you know, the, the duties assigned to me,
um, accomplished and, and also still trying to be a strategic leader and,
and, and that sort of stuff, but that's the same place, you know,
exploring and trying to find in, in this market, which still, which
even within Microsoft is tough, um, trying to find a better match.
As we have said on the podcast multiple times before, right.
When, when there's a misalignment between what your intrinsic business
and the business by which you are funded, right.
And I'm shortcutting this because I think we had a wittier quote, but
you either change your job or you change your job, right?
You change your manager, you change your manager, same thing.
Yeah.
And, and so I took the ladder and in a new position and, um, now I'll,
I'll segue and as I was thinking through once that all landed, I was
going, I was thinking through, uh, the, the podcast, I was thinking
through modern testing principles.
I was thinking through AI education.
I even, um, spent a lot of time thinking around like the last, last time
I was on the cast with, with Jason Arbin, where he predicted, you know,
eventually we'll all be quality assistants, um, or quality in the QA business.
I, I will be curious if he still holds that opinion.
He does, I guarantee he does not because his new manifesto is pitching
the idea that the new, the new role that QA's do evolve into is a
confidence engineer, which I don't fully agree with.
I think there's, there's something there, but it's not the right.
We don't need another.
I think there's something, I think there's something there.
Exactly.
There's something there, but it's not the right, to me, it's
not the right something, not quite.
And even with his statement around quality, there's something there.
Right.
But, um, I think where we're heading into is going to be a lot more organic.
And then I sat back and I was, I was thinking about modern testing principles.
And I was thinking about one of the things Alan and I would say on the
podcast quite often is that we knew, we knew these had an expiration date.
We didn't, we didn't know when that was.
And suddenly a bunch of things connected for me.
I, I spent about a half hour, an hour on open, uh, on chat GPT, trying to
work through my thought processes and organize them.
And then I had a click and I texted Alan and I said, okay, I'm ready
to come back to the podcast.
Things are clear.
And I gave him a teaser that I had a topic for us to discuss.
Um, and that is, I do feel modern testing principles have expired.
That I don't think, uh, if you are still in a QA only world, right.
I don't know if you should still follow that or just leapfrog to the next thing.
I get where you're going and we've talked about it, but I want to push
back on that a little bit because as we know the modern testing principles
were never about testing, they were about delivery.
We were trying to help.
It says 15 years ago at the beginning, you know, not the beginning of
agile, but the beginning of agile from Microsoft, a bunch of folks
and we're struggling like, Oh, everything's moving so much faster.
How do I make sure I stay relevant in testing?
And so it's like help accelerate the achieve in a shippable quality.
It's, um, so the help on improving the business, um, theory of constraints,
um, continuous improvement, quality culture, um, customer, customer data
for quality, um, data in general and expanding knowledge across the
team versus siloing knowledge.
Those things are all still true today.
And I would say, I would argue in some, I'm going to get,
I'm going to get somewhere here.
I would argue that with the speed of AI development, those
things are super important.
Brian Finster is on the podcast a while back, uh, talks a lot on
LinkedIn about how, if, if you can do continuous delivery, if you can
actually deploy every check-in, whether it's AI or not, and have
the right confidence, that's for you, Jason, have the right confidence
to verify that in prod or roll it back, uh, if you can do that now
without AI, you don't have that human bottleneck at the end.
And that's, and that's the thing teams are struggling with right now
is the human bottleneck in the loop.
It was, it would pop up a lot of times in agile.
It's constant in teams that are delivering with AI speed.
So those principles are, I think, here's my statement.
The modern testing principles are still applicable today, but
they're in, they're, they're insufficient.
They're insufficient definition of, of how teams deliver in this new world.
Well, so what I want to do in, so I'll just, I'll just go this way.
Right now it occurred to me, and this was the final thought
before I started texting out, I'm like, holy crap, we are right
now in the middle of the same sort of cultural shift, uh, that we
were in, you know, maybe a year before we actually decided to write
10 X or a hundred X as far as shift goes, it's a, it's the same kind of
shift X a factor or more intense.
Yes.
And so what I put together is sort of a beginning of a thought process
around this, I believe it is time to create in this is the name I'm
toying with the postmodern engineering principles.
We had a podcast once a long time ago.
I, in fact, I did like a postmodern postmodern testing talk, but
it was nothing about this.
So yeah, anyway, continue.
And it's, it, um, so postmodernism is a thing.
Of course it is.
Yeah.
And I looked up before, cause I didn't want it to just, you
know, what's after modern testing principles.
I didn't want it to just bolt on the post.
Um, but it's a working name, but I, I'm like, okay, there's an opportunity
here for, for us to leverage the podcast again, to help guide the
next set of people along with the current set.
And if we do this right, as we did before, uh, we can get the
community involved and folks can kind of hear us as we think it out loud.
Yeah.
Cause we don't know the answer yet.
We, we did not like the principles for those who've been listening for
like a million fricking years, which is nobody, because our listening
basis died out and they're been replaced by a new three.
Um, we started like, we had to vet these principles for a while.
I was like, oh, no, that's not right.
All right.
And then we even modified them once along the way to kind of, to
make them a little bit more, uh, more better anyway, I liked the idea.
And I like what you wrote, but it's not right.
And I replied with my own take on, we'll call it post-modern testing for now.
It might be a better name.
Um, and neither one of those are right.
And, but some nuggets of it may be.
So how do you want to start?
Do you want, let's talk more about like what you're thinking about here.
So let me, let me go through and I'll, I'll, I'll read to you.
What I sent you as a teaser topic.
Okay.
Cause, cause, cause I'm looking at your full notes you sent me
and it's like 17 pages.
Yeah.
And then you said you went and tweaked it and I don't have a link to that
when I think it's a separate context.
Oh, I have it.
But anyway, give me your stuff and then, um, yeah, we'll get,
we'll get to mine if we have time.
Let me, let me read what I sent you as a, as a sort of a teaser abstract.
Okay.
Yeah.
Uh, the other thing that I'm going to call out last time you and I not
only had evidence from the world, but we had lived experience around,
uh, the modern testing principles, right?
The thing I'm seeing right now is like, okay, it's changing.
Um, and it's changing so fast.
I don't think it's going to be fully likely that either of us are going
to have a complete set of lived experience on this one.
Okay.
So, but I still think it's important.
So, uh, anyone listening, like whatever Alan and I come up with, it's
not going to be, um, in stone.
Well, we're trying to work through is what is a better direction for
what's, um, for where we're going.
Yeah.
Now, so here's, here's what I sent out postmodern engineering principles,
postmodern engineering recognizes that software is no longer
created solely by humans.
Systems are increasingly probabilistic and organizational capability
emerges from the interaction of people, AI agents, platforms, and context.
The prints are the, the engineering philosophy rejects rigid boundaries
between builder and user development in operations, testing and production,
human and machine intelligence, and even implementation and strategy.
Engineering becomes the continuous orchestration of adaptive social
technical systems towards trustworthy outcomes.
That's what I said.
I am that last sentence, like I am 120% aboard that that is where we're going.
Yeah.
I think it, and actually, I think it goes farther.
Um, something you don't mention directly in there.
You may imply something that's coming up a lot as I think
about it, as I talk to companies, uh, software development is no longer
limited to those who have traditionally been developers.
We have people in marketing, legal sales, uh, you name it, HR
creating software via vibe coding and using those tools to improve their
software, improve their lives.
Is, are there still people in the world today that haven't connected
the dots that coding is now a commodity?
Yes, absolutely.
People have not connected those dots.
Okay.
That's that's part of these principles is connecting those
dots is coding coding was never was the hard part.
And now it's the easy part.
Yes.
But what does that leave us?
And this is a, this is part of the, of the story that I, so number one,
so we've, we've talked about like one of the, the MTP principles,
I think is, is CICD.
Okay.
Yes.
Um, this really needs to reinforce, uh, a concept that you don't hear a
lot of, and, um, and I do think we've used this term, but the
term itself is going to have to change.
And the term is continuous feedback.
Okay.
Cause continuous feedback, we talk about, Oh, we need to send out a survey
or we need to collect data or we need to blah, blah, blah, blah.
It's too slow.
When I say continuous feedback, I'm talking millisecond.
I'm talking minute, you know, something along those lines.
Which is, which is why I think, um, why our principle on theory of
constraints is, is even more critical now, because the bottlenecks used to
be days or hours, and now it's seconds and milliseconds optimizations
we're thinking we're making.
And I'm not going to push back, but the thing I'm not going to
agree yet either, but, but we're brainstorming.
So theory of constraints, the key thing, right?
Theory of constraints, batch size, everything from Ryan Anderson's book.
Um, I go back and reread it with this new light.
Okay.
But I do think all of that's going to be the case.
Now the first one thing, the one thing that I'm going to stay
firm on when people, when I'm talking about the agentification
and AI, okay.
Number one, um, it hurts my soul to say this, but AI is now this LLM thing.
Okay.
It used to be, you know, data science and all of that was AI, but the world
has, has changed the definition to specifically mean it's this LLM
chatbot agent, blah, blah, blah.
Now, um, AI is probably no different than a simulated human.
Okay.
So the very first thing that's important for everyone to realize
is AI is not magic.
It's not the silver bullet that's going to come and solve every problem.
Uh, there was an absolutely fantastic study, uh, and actually,
um, uh, Alan, Alan saw this comment and he actually connected with me
because Patrick, Patrick Prill, a longtime listener, um, made a statement
on LinkedIn and I, I corrected him on it.
Now, one thing that's important, things are changing all the time.
Um, I have actually vibe coded a system that will go out and look
at Google scholar and say, all right, run these, these keywords and send
me anything that's new and relevant because I have no idea what I may
share today that may have been in, um, uh, that I learned two weeks ago
that it may have already been invalidated yesterday.
I have no idea.
Right.
And, and so that sort of constantly, that's actually kind of the, the, the
point of the continuous feedback.
If you know, like in order to optimize, you have to have something
that they can say, okay, based off to today, what's now true.
Okay.
And, and that's where kind of the post-modernism comes in because
the definition of true is going to change context quite frequently.
Now, um, do you want, do you have anything else you want to say?
Cause I kind of want to go back to my statement and mention a couple
things that I think are critically important.
And we're going to talk thematically this time, cause we're not going to
get to the actual principles cause you and I have a different take on those.
But I rewrote, I took a discerning rewrite of what you just said a
minute ago about what post-modern engineering is, and I added a few
things that I think to me make it resonate more, and we're going to
go back and forth and these is fine.
But those you have with your photographic memory, imagine what
Brent said, and I'm going to say largely the same thing with a little bit of
rewrite, uh, post-modern engineering recognizes that software is no longer
created solely by humans.
Systems are increasingly probabilistic and organizational capability emerges
from the interaction of people, AI agents, platforms, and context.
It rejects rigid boundaries between builder and user development operations.
As you said, testing and production, um, and builder can be anyone.
We should maybe qualify that more human and machine intelligence
implementation strategy.
And then the part I added at the end is software engineering becomes
the continuous orchestration of adaptive, socio-technical systems.
Cause, cause systems are, systems are still people and tech adaptive
socio-technical systems towards trustworthy outcomes, which is the
part needs to be emphasized and we can use AI to help with that.
Cause people are worried about using AI because, oh, it may make
something insecure and likely it will.
So, but you can use agents to help with that too.
Right.
But you have, but the goal is still not just, it's not just to be fast.
It's to be fast.
And, and, and I'm not even going to say good, good enough.
I will, but I like the idea of continuous feedback in there too.
But anyway, I, I don't, I don't, I didn't actually pick up a
difference that I cared about.
So that, that's, that's fun.
Um, the continuous is absolutely at least an order of magnitude faster
than, than when we did MTP, right.
And even then, and even then when we did that, it was an order, at
least an order of magnitude faster than, right.
We went from shipping every two years of shipping every with, with
being, you know, dozens and dozens, maybe a hundred times a day.
And now we're still doing hundreds or maybe thousands of time a day, but
lines of, but those changes are bigger sometimes often too.
So one of the things that I think is going to be really important, we've
talked about it multiple times, but I do think in the post-engineering
world, okay, number one, um, every study that I have observed, and again,
under the idea that an AI today is nothing more than a simulated human.
Uh, the, the, just as an example, uh, there was a great study that came out
in, I think it was March and they were, cause there was a lot of theory.
Oh, that's the one I posted in Patrick's brain.
That's what the story, there's a lot of theory around, oh, but AI
writes on maintainable code.
This, this study was the first of its kind where it actually
used, uh, professional developers, not like college students.
And what they found was that there was no statistical difference in the
maintainability of a professional devs code or the code purely generated by AI.
Yeah.
And you can compensate.
And here's the funny part is going to hold up the key thing.
Wait, I'll let you go.
But the key thing on that one is that there's no difference.
No, I get it.
Which, which means AI is far from perfect.
It makes human level errors.
Yes.
And yes, this is the, what I find funny, but true is, you know, how you
address the shortcomings with AI more AI to a point.
Let me give you an example.
I talked to a lot of companies like, this is what I hear a lot.
Uh, we use AI a lot for development, but we still have humans review code.
Okay.
That's a bottleneck.
We have humans review some of the code.
Okay.
Well, I mean, I get it.
And do you remember a million years ago, um, like at Microsoft in the old, in
the old slow days, uh, there were like, uh, some of the check-in tools had
a risk analysis built in, they look at the change and, and what parts it
changed and where the bugs were before and like co-complex a bunch of
different stuff and give it a risk factor that told you how seriously to
take the code review, basically.
Um, a one AI can create that algorithm for you in moments.
Have an agent, an agent reviewer.
And if you feel like you need to have a human involved, uh, again,
cause it's the same as humans.
I mean, and, but I think, I think the review can be better in fact,
the review is better and faster with AI assistance and it can tell you
when it may make sense to get a human set of eyes on it.
And I think most of the time that human wouldn't find anything new,
but at least you'd have some confidence going back to nod to Jason.
But I think you can use, there's a shortcoming, a bottleneck,
a risk, uh, I'm worried about security issues.
Great.
Let me, let me spin up a security reviewer and a pen tester to check
out my changes and give me that confidence via machinery and AI that
I used to take me days to get in the past on the same page.
Um, the, the, the thing is, um, it is still absolutely the case.
So it's good at, at, at simulating human, um, in, in this, this is something
that I will continue to find, but everybody who's, who's like, oh,
the AI is actually thinking, no, it is goddamn not.
It's still a generation machine.
Yes.
It will tell you what's thinking in this little prompt feedback, but it's
not, it's not, it is a fancy word completion algorithm.
It is still a parrot mimicking humans, but it's getting a lot better.
And again, it still produces errors, at least according to this study
at the same rate as humans do, which means what, right.
Which means if you're interacting with an AI and you're interacting
with a human, it does actually make sense for you to have the same
sort of critical thought, right.
It's like, okay, I know Alan, Alan's great guy.
Uh, and he wrote this code.
Well, I'm going to review his code as if I'm doing any code review, right.
Now, if I actually still reviewed code, which I don't, um, I, I review outcomes.
So one of the things that I had talked to Alan about, so I created my own team
of agents, uh, I modeled them after an actual, uh, production team, right.
I have a project owner and I have a builder and a developer and blah, blah,
blah, blah, and I play the role of essentially like, um, uh, a
pump or a manager of this team.
And, and they'll, uh, so like the traditional project owner role, and you
can go to back and look at agile.
That's where they go.
This is my acceptance criteria.
Everything else is a black box.
I don't care, but this has got to pass this acceptance criteria.
Um, and so when it says, okay, I'm done, I go when
I do the acceptance review.
Are you familiar with interject here?
Cause you can do this at home kids.
Are you familiar with paperclip?
Not clippy from Microsoft paperclip.
It's basically this.
Um, the first, the first, I don't want to call it a person persona
you create is a CEO.
You've created a CEO.
You give an admission statement and add some context.
And then let me finish, let me finish it and then you can create your
develop, you create all the roles you want and, and, and describe
how they interact at each one is gentic.
And what's really cool is you can hook these up to any engine.
And the folks who are being successful with it are like doing one senior
engineer as air quotes in there, uh, running Claude, one of the paid systems.
Then you use one of the, you make like two or three junior engineers who use
the free or very cheap systems for their AI might make more mistakes.
But then the senior, then the senior reviewer and the CTO come in and
review code as needed from those junior engineers, just like they
would in the real world.
And what it means is like, there's part of this evolvement that probably
has come up with these principles is everyone's an agent manager, uh,
because kind of what you're doing, I think everybody, and maybe it's
the folks in marketing and sales and legal who are maybe vibe coding
to something directly, but develop, but the traditional developers, they
should be managing a team of agents to help build what they need to build.
Yeah, this, this is 100% true.
And I will say, so I built my, my thing over last Christmas holiday.
Um, uh, and shortly after that, a bunch of other things, um, similar.
Uh, I have told my team, um, like my team, I released it to them.
They have access to it.
I'm like, I don't care if you use this system or make your own, like,
cause I do think it's, again, it's about trustworthy outcomes.
Now the system that I've done, it gives me transparency.
Like when the agents make a decision, uh, I, I require them
to log out the decision making.
So I, like, for me, the ability to see what's going on as it goes
through, um, and, and being able to audit that decision-making was, was
important for me to gain trust around when I can just let the
thing just go or not, right.
Um, cause it, it's, it's, it's just as much around using the tool
as, as learning how to use it right.
Um, and for me and for each person, that definition of right, I
think is going to change.
Now we're running out of time, but I do want to hit a couple of things
that I think are going to be super important.
Number one, we have talked about systems all the time on this.
Everything's a system.
And if you've, if you've read the, I know you want to talk, but
I've been writing all summer since I got back about how quality is a system.
And Elizabeth Hendrickson and I talked about it quite a bit on her
podcast and on AB testing, but yeah.
Yes.
Systems, systems, systems.
I do think, um, so if we look at MTP and we go, oh, you know what?
We can easily argue that some of the principles came directly out of,
you know, certain textbooks and things like that.
Sure.
Um, I think a, a critical precursor, um, not a precursor, but a prereq for
mastering the world that's coming is systems theory.
And I don't mean glancingly.
I mean actual, right?
Um, system and just so that people understand when I say system, I'm
talking about in the system theory context, I'll briefly describe it.
And then I'm going to move on.
Okay.
And then if you describe it, that I'm going to comment, then
you're going to move on.
Fair enough.
A system is a group of interconnected component such that when they are
working together, they create a property that belongs to that system
that doesn't exist in any of the components.
Okay.
So one, my, my favorite example of a system is automobile.
Automobile has an engine, it has tires, has a transmission brakes,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
But none of these components and a bitch in car stereo and a bitch in
car stereo, but none of these components have the property that the
car does, which is the capability to transit from A to B.
Okay.
That is the system.
It's when these components, like the human body is also a system, right?
The circular tip system combines with the nervous system, right?
And in the, uh, here's, here's the vocab word of the day, kids, homeostasis.
Look it up.
Can't go into it now.
It's an important theme going forward.
Homeostasis.
Um, so there are two things I think that are important that we're going
into in this future world, right?
Number one, trust for the outcomes as both Alan and I said are critical.
We're going into a place where, um, for those, I'm going to use
the term I have ever done it before, but in economics or product
development, there's this thing called a moat.
So if you thought of your company or your product as a castle,
what's the thing that protects it?
Okay.
With agents, um, with, when we shifted into the world of agile, like
switching costs was the biggest threat.
Agents make that even better, right?
It's, it's okay.
I'm, I'm fricking, fricking tired of GCP.
I'm moving to Amazon.
Okay.
Agents could write me the throwaway code.
I don't care if it's a, it only needs to work once.
It only needs to work once.
Right.
Um, the, and even if it doesn't fully work, I'll use an agent to say,
okay, fix the gaps, right?
This is, and I'm going to put in here, this is, this is the, what we're
seeing with the big innovation we're seeing and the move even with non
developers writing code is there are things we never would have bothered
to write the code before that are now trivial.
We're solving problems that weren't worth solving before.
And, and, but they're still problems.
And I've encountered that repeatedly over the last year.
I do it in my own life.
I am automating so much of what I do just with little things.
Do you know, there's a script in our, um, our modern testing repo
that AI and I wrote that will automatically look for any episodes
that haven't been transcribed using whisper, uh, download them from
Spotify, transcribe them, and then check in the transcribed files into
our repo.
I did not know that, but it doesn't surprise me.
And then I can put all that I put all the, I tell you this, then I
can put all of the transcripts into like notebook LLM and I can ask
questions like, what was the episode where Brent was eating food during
the podcast?
It'll give me, it gave me two examples where I made fun of you
for eating during the podcast.
F and cool.
Anyway, go on.
Now that's fun.
I wouldn't have bothered writing that in the old days.
No, no, because it's all about R Y right?
Yeah.
And you're like, okay, moved substantially.
The, the R is, is still the same amount, but the eye has gotten so much
cheaper.
It's so tiny.
Like if I have an idea, I can go implement it.
And that's where the critical thinking, just to get my comment in
here, I know we have to go in a minute.
Um, the critical thinking really jumps in is being able to prompt properly.
I hate the term prompt engineer, but that critical thinking, like if two
different developers create, give them the same problem, they're going to
create different markdown in their agents to try and address that problem.
And they're going to get two different answers.
And they're both correct and wrong in their own ways, but one is
probably more correct.
I'm going to shut up and let you finish.
I don't know that even more correct is, is it, because again, we're
heading towards a world that is going to be probabilistic.
Okay.
In it, in it, or you're ignoring it.
Now, one of the things that I think is as, as an aside, right.
Um, and this kind of goes to the token epidemic is people are, are perhaps
overusing that particular tool, right?
And it's not the silver bullet.
I'm like, okay, so if you have a simple decision tree, if it goes
down the A path, if this condition goes down the A path or go down
the B path, why do you need an AI making that decision all the time?
Like you don't need to waste tokens.
It's a simple if statement, right.
And that's the whole thing.
Determinism is still valuable, right.
Um, and it's actually cheaper.
It's just, you have to think of it more thoughtfully.
The other thing is that in your example around the
transition from GCP to AWS.
Okay.
That's us about software.
It's the outcome that they're looking for.
If the outcome's repeatable, right.
If the outcome is, oh, I want to come back and see the trends, right.
There's some storage thing.
It's we're no longer trying to sell software, trying to sell outcomes.
And in this world, this is the thing that I think is super critical.
If, if the only thing is trust, that means trust with the outcomes are going
to be super critical because the switching costs, if they don't trust me,
they're going to go someplace else.
However, right.
A lot of the traditions is, oh, we have to slow down quality test, test,
test, test, test, test, test, test.
Nope.
We can't make a mistake.
I'm going to tell everybody who's listening, the companies that are going
to win are going to be the number one, the ones who understand customer
problems in near real time and react and solve their problems equally in
near real time.
Yes.
It's that closed loop that is important.
And, and just like what we were talking about MTP, what, what got us
to the agile world is like the waterfall world is dead.
I don't know if the agile world is dead, right?
Because by its definition agile is just, you know, reacting faster, but
it's reacting faster to a degree we've not seen before and it
might be worth a new name.
Yes.
So we're out of time.
I'm going to drop a cliffhanger for next time.
And then we're going to continue this conversation because what you
just talked about is the first principle of what we're talking about
that we agreed on the name of.
I'm just going to drop that because it's directly related to what you
just said, and then we're, then we're going to say goodbye.
Okay.
Outcomes are contextual and continuously negotiated.
No comment.
Can leave that there.
Brent, it's good to have you back.
Um, see you next time.
All right.
Yes.
Thank you everyone.
Bye.